Asymmetric collapse, asymmetric collapse with straight-ahead flight.
With asymmetric collapse, like with various other collapses, it's the case that, when
we collapse one side, it brakes the wing — so remember,
pulling ears, everything that collapses brakes; in this case it brakes the right side considerably,
and a movement to the right would actually result.
So the wing would happily build up dynamics to the right — we don't want that.
We want, we want with that collapse to (unclear)
of which side.
And then we want to slow that down with the counter-brake. Why with the counter-brake — I'll explain right away.
In theory, it's like this — you also have to tick this off, if the question comes up in flight practice.
To stabilise the asymmetric collapse, you additionally have to put body weight onto this open side and brake a bit less with it.
But in practice it's like this: with a 50% collapse maybe that still works.
With 60–70% — which really is more of the problem for us — that doesn't work any more.
That means, you have so much load gone from the right riser. You can't manage to lean over to the left side at all.
And it's not even productive. If we let the weight fall onto the collapsed side,
then the riser is first loaded again on that side.
That means we help the wing much sooner to re-open.
So, letting the weight fall — you can also remember this for flying.
Letting body weight fall is always good — you always load exactly the side that needs to be loaded right then.
That's why we do it that way too.
Good, how can we fly the whole thing?
Correct is of course that we try to collapse this 40–50% surface.
And we manage that by first of all, on the collapse side, fixing the brake to the press-stud.
Or magnet, like here — it doesn't matter.
Or you just let it go, but don't keep it in your hand.
Because if we now pull the A-risers and have the brake in the hand, the brake maybe gets messed up,
then it doesn't really know what it should do — should it collapse, or should it re-open.
So brake away, best to fix it, then it makes the least chaos.
The other brake stays unwrapped, but right up at the bridle in the hand.
There, if you want, you can brace yourself a bit on the riser,
so the hand doesn't fly off somewhere into nothing.
So lightly braced on the riser.
Never grip the riser, but always only brace on it.
Good, then come maybe also a bit forward.
It's important that you absolutely come over the line locks, all the A-lines.
That means, also the high-attachment aids.
You have to take them along too.
So all the A-lines that you have, take along — grab above the line locks like this:
little fingers up, and index finger and thumb wrap around the line lock,
so above the line lock.
And then you can pull — at the beginning pull a bit slowly,
then fix the A-lines, because otherwise it opens straight back up on you.
Pull, and where you have it just right, you can hold yourself on the main riser.
And now carefully work with the left brake.
All by feel, search for straight flight, search for straight-ahead flight.
And then with the, straight-ahead flight,
the 13,000, with the fingers.
It's not necessarily the case
that you pull the brake and can then keep it there,
but you may have to work a bit.
That's why searching for this flight is so important,
look at a fixed point in the terrain to the wing,
look forward.
Aha, now I'm flying straight ahead, wonderful.
Now comes the command from me, release the collapse.
Okay, then the right hand — as the collapsed side — simply goes up.
The left hand keeps searching for straight-ahead flight.
Until the collapse is out.
And then the counter-brake can simply be released up.
Under no circumstances simply let everything go,
because if the collapse is in, then we turn off to the right onto the collapsed side.
We don't want that.
So that's why, just stabilise the opposite side
until the collapse is out.
If it doesn't come out on its own,
then we grab the brake, take the brake and pump once.
Snap!
Pay!
Still straight-ahead flight.
How to stabilise?
Look — where's it going?
All right.
Wing is still not open.
21, 22, 22.
Damn, I'll give it one more, right?
Then it's open.
And if I had to pump again,
but always at about two, three seconds apart.
And if that's the case,
it's not the case here in the courtyard.
Then we can wait again with both hands.
Or, with the ears hand all the way up.
Now!
Why work so carefully with the counter-brake?
We have a very, very short steering travel.
We have 50% surface that we have collapsed.
That means we still only have 50% surface that's flying.
Wing loading rises enormously.
And with wing loading the stall point also rises.
That means, we've reached the stall point much sooner.
So steering travel has become noticeably shorter.
And the pressure in the wing.
So, just on the side, on the brake — it's enormously high.
That means, brake pressure has also become higher.
So you really have to fly sensitively,
very sensitively searching for straight-ahead flight.
And the whole thing of course, train it a couple of times.
Once left, once right,
so we don't get too set in our ways.
Okay.
If we've now gotten too little surface in for the asymmetric collapse,
then we can go at it again.
So let go, I'll say, let go again,
go at it again.
Then we have to try to pull a bit more aggressively.
We have to always come to 50%.
We're also allowed in training to fly 60%.
Or 70% goes, depending, when we have good altitude.
But the important thing is, when we really have too little.
And it's like, 40%, then I say to you,
a bit more aggressively.
So then we can go at it.
Pull a bit more aggressively.
Maybe then pull a bit deeper too.
And the wing also lays itself much better backwards from the collapse.
And then again on exactly the same — carefully counter.
Just so far that it flies straight ahead
and hold the straight-ahead, until the command-giver lets the collapse out.
And then again, nothing first — release the collapse,
and then the brake, when the wing is open.
Simply that's it for the collapse.
Once right, once left — always remember.
On the collapse side, fix the brake beforehand.
Because if you don't,
and I think, when pulled down, you'll see.
The wing won't collapse very well.
There it really needs the brake free,
so not even kept in the hand.
Good, okay.